[Musique]
messieurs dames on ne devient pas
policier par hasard
policiers ce métier que j'ai exercé
pendant quinze ans est avant tout une
vocation
j'ai longtemps cherché par le passé de
quelle façon je pouvais me rendre utile
à cette société quelle était la
profession que j'allais exercer et la
différence ce qui en a fait une vocation
c'est que c'est ce métier qui est venu à
moi au final
donc c'était un métier
particulièrement éprouvant
avec une devise protéger et servir il
existe aussi d'autres vocations les
pompiers parlent de sauver ou périr
des enseignants évoquent la transmission
j'ai aussi une pensée particulière et je
voudrais profiter de l'audience qui
m'est donnée pour avoir une pensée pour
le corps des soignants particulièrement
éprouvée ces derniers temps
alors pour ma part j'ai été ce qu'on
appelle un agent secret un espion alors
je me permets une parenthèse puisque
j'évoque ce sujet là je voudrais dire à
l'étudiant qui porte un masque
chirurgical à chaque fois que je croise
depuis hier que je ne suis plus un
espion et je ne suis pas là pour lui
donc il évoque la variole du singe
évidemment mais je voudrais lui faire
savoir qu'il n'a rien à craindre de
l'ancien espion que j'ai été
alors se maintenant ce qui est dit n'est
plus à dire
alors la difficulté de ce métier outre
sa difficulté extrinsèque la
confrontation à des radicalités
extrêmement violente et à des nouvelles
menaces émergentes c'est aussi la
renonciation à la reconnaissance agir
dans l'ombre
accepté l'idée d'être méconnu
pour la majorité d'entre vous tout ce
qui ne se voit pas n'existe pas or il
existe dans l'ombre
de façon extrêmement discrète
volontairement peu disque peu ostensible
de nombreuses équipes à travers le
territoire qui veille sur votre sécurité
c'est un travail de longue haleine un
effort permanent fournies par les
services de l'état dont j'ai été l'un
des serviteurs pendant ses nombreuses
années
alors on va avoir besoin de la police
pendant ces prochaines années même si
effectivement la critique à juste titre
et vous savez bien qu'en tant que
syndicaliste j'ai été particulièrement
exposés à la critique justement de cette
institution on va en avoir besoin au
regard du contexte la polarisation notre
société l'émergence de nouvelles menaces
dans un contexte géopolitique sans
précédent un contexte de crise sanitaire
un contexte de menaces terroristes comme
on n'en a jamais connue en france donc
la police est plus que jamais nécessaire
et il ya besoin de la réforme et
permettez moi une autre parenthèse alors
c'est l'occasion de faire savoir qu en
tant que syndicaliste naturellement on
reçoit assez souvent des convocations ça
fait partie du jeu donc alors en 2017
j'ai reçu une première convocation qui
est celle ci donc alors qu'est ce qui
vous frappe dans cette convocation c'est
qu'il s'agit en fait d'un télégramme le
cas télégramme alors comme le facteur me
l'a apportée il savait pas ce que
c'était il m'a dit effectivement dans
mon bureau de poste on n'en avait pas vu
depuis 1978 le voilà alors orange a
décrété en avril 2018 puisqu'elle est
l'héritière des ptt que le télégramme ne
devrait plus exister et en fait ils ont
mis fin mai la police a eu recours au
télégramme jusqu'en 2017 tout ça pour
vous dire qu'effectivement il ya
beaucoup de choses à repenser dans la
façon de restructurer l'institution
créée on est confronté à des nouvelles
menaces la cyber criminalité la
délinquance financière la délinquance
astucieuse et c'est donc il faut à tout
prix serait adapté et ça a été mon
combat en tant que syndicaliste que j'ai
firme emmené et aujourd'hui je suis
content de passer le flambeau à la
génération suivante
alors pour ma part on m'a demandé de
vous ouvrir la voie ou de quelle manière
à ce que je peux vous aime je pouvais
vous ouvrir la voie alors moi
personnellement je suis ce qu'on
appellerait un autodidacte c'est à dire
que dans le sens où j'ai un parcours non
linéaire alors les parcours non
linéaires sont effectivement valoriser
dans notre société contrairement à
d'autres sociétés où on hérite de la
noblesse on hérite d'un patrimoine en
france on peut partir de rien et arriver
à des choses et ces choses j'ai pu la
réaliser grâce à ce qu'on appelle des
rencontres providentielles alors nous
sommes dans une société méritocratique
et grâce au travail nous pouvons obtenir
des résultats et nous structurer et
trouver notre place au sein de cette
société alors moi je suis né d'une
famille ouvrière d'origine immigrée j'ai
grandi dans un quartier sensible à
goussainville j'ai été scolarisé dans
une zone d'éducation prioritaire tout me
prédestinait davantage à devenir un
voyou plutôt qu'un policier plutôt qu un
fervent défenseur de la nation
et j'ai fait des rencontres
providentielles j'ai eu des rencontres
providentielles qui m'ont sauvé la vie
alors ouvrir la voie qu'est ce que ça
m'évoque après mon service militaire
parce qu'il fut une époque effectivement
où tous les français se mélanger pour
servir la nation quelques mois durant
j'ai par la suite pris l'initiative
d'aller en vacances à bourg saint
maurice avec deux chasseurs alpins pour
affronter la montagne très orgueilleux
très viril on a décidé de monter
sur 700 m de dénivelé
avec une neige poudreuse 20 peut-être 30
cm et eux m'ont laissé passer ils m'ont
demandé d'ouvrir la voie de faire la
trace pour ceux qui connaissent donc
naturellement j'ai commencé debout fière
et j'ai fini à quatre pattes
complètement essoufflé et donc tout ça
pour vous dire que la vie en fait c'est
un peu la montagne si vous voulez vous
gagner jamais face à la vie si vous
l'appréhendez de la mauvaise manière
avec les mauvaises outils donc il faut
toujours réfléchir à la façon dont on
appréhende la vie et à ce qu'on veut
faire de notre passage sur terre donc la
vocation permet d'améliorer son
environnement d'agir positivement sur
les gens qui nous entourent
alors ma première rencontre
présidentielle c'est l'école
républicaine alors l'école républicaine
parce que j'ai pu manger à la cantine
c'est mon seul repas équilibré de la
journée j'ai pu effectivement assurer
les conditions de croissance de cette
façon là mais on m'a aussi transmis
l'amour de la langue française j'ai lu
molière j'ai lu l'intégralité de
l'oeuvre de marcel pagnol la trilogie de
jules vallès on m'a donné l'amour des
lettres malgré une scolarisation dans
une filière technique mais on m'a donné
la langue française et l'amour de cette
de ce patrimoine comme une clé une clé
qui ouvrirait toutes les portes on ne
peut pas comprendre la technologie on ne
peut pas comprendre le commerce on ne
peut pas comprendre les sciences
humaines
si on ne maîtrise pas et si on n'a pas
accès à la langue française aujourd'hui
j'ai vendu plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'exemplaires de mes deux
livres et le troisième est en cours
d'écriture moi qui suis originaire de
goussainville ma deuxième rencontre
providentielle alors elle s'explique par
un parcours de vie un peu atypique je
suis né à ces jeunes on m'a diagnostiqué
ce qu'on appelait du rachitisme c'est à
dire un déficit en calcium qui déformait
mais oh mais les médecins ont prédit que
je n'exercerai jamais une activité
physique
éprouvante physiquement du moins
j'étais scolarisés en zone d'éducation
prioritaire donc mes chances de succès
étaient assez amoindri
je me suis retranchée derrière les
études j'ai travaillé dur et j'ai obtenu
un bac avec mention qui m'a permis
ensuite de scolariser en bts
mais effectivement quartiers
prioritaires en quartiers sensibles
être un élève studieux c'est s'exposer à
l'agressivité de l'environnement à la
délinquance aux brimades mais aucun
moment j'ai voulu apprendre à me
défendre n'ayant pas les moyens de
suivre des cours de karaté j'ai décidé
de me rendre en tant que spectateur et
je prenais des notes et le prof de
karaté est venu vers moi et m'a dit mais
pourquoi est-ce que tu prends des notes
qu'est ce que tu cherches qu'est ce que
tu écris sur ton papier jill craybas
écoutez moi j'écris je prends note de
certaines de vos techniques
d'entraînement puis je vais les
reproduire chez moi une fois je serais
rentré il m'a dit non non ça écoute tu
arrêtes tout de suite vient lundi on
trouvera un kimono tu vas t'entraîner
chez moi gratuitement je te demanderai
en échange si ce n'est la ponctualité
l'assiduité et le sérieux
l'investissement dans son entraînement
donc j'ai fini ceinture noire 1re dan et
j'ai étudié quatre ans en staps à la fac
des sports donc voilà ensuite
alors bts service militaire deux ans
quatre en staps j'ai toujours sur le
marché de l'emploi
ma compagne est enceinte on attend notre
premier enfant et je me pose la question
de savoir comment est ce que je vais les
ducs et dans ce monde
ce monde extrêmement agressif à tous les
niveaux violence institutionnelle
violences physiques
individualisme j'essaye de trouver ma
place est à ce moment là je me rends à
l'université fête étudiante et on a un
mécène de l'université qui vient il dit
moi je gère des entreprises je suis un
investisseur et j'ai entre autres une
ss2i qui fonctionnent assez bien et on
produit des logiciels d application etc
à destination de différentes
collectivités tu m'as l'air d'être
quelqu'un de bien j'aimerais aider
est-ce qu'on peut discuter d'une
éventuelle embauche qu'est ce que tu
sais faire
je vous explique mon parcours mais ds
électronique fac des sports etc ils
m'arrêtent tout de suite en me disant
bon jeu peut rien en faire pourquoi
parce que moi je ne suis pas
aigri mais
mon entreprise n'a pas de vocation
sociale mon but c'est de gagner de
l'argent si j'investis un euro pour te
rémunéré il faut que j'ai la garantie
que tu puisses mans rapporter au minimum
3 sinon je ne le ferai pas je n'ai
aucune raison de le faire qu'est ce que
vous voulez répondre à ça j'étais
forcément d'accord avec lui il m'a dit
bon écoute 28 ans et vous savez mieux
que moi ici à l'école des mines il m'a
dit 28 ans c'est pas un fred un jeune
diplômé sans expérience les salariés de
28 ans que j'ai ce sont des ingénieurs
qui ont été diplômés à 23 ans et qui ont
5 ans d'expérience à ton niveau tu
pourras pas concurrencer ces gens là
passent un concours administratif prof
autre regarde la liste des concours
administratifs et essaye de faire
carrière dans l'administration
effectivement c'est ce que j'ai fait en
rentrant chez moi j'étais bouleversée
j'ai vu effectivement qui avait un
recrutement au niveau des forces de
police un concours tous les trois mois
une volonté puisqu'on était pendant la
crise des banlieues de 2005 à
clichy-sous-bois volonté des états de
s'ouvrir un public diversifié pour
renforcer les effectifs de police et
donc je passe le concours de police
niveau bac
environ 15 de moyenne générale sur le
concours admis à la première tentative
j'entre en école de police non sans
péripéties ça peu difficile de dormir
dans des chambres et de se remettre à
réviser de courir infiniment
inlassablement autour du stade
j'y vais je passe mon année de scolarité
je suis affecté en sécurité publique
dans le 93 et là
tout de suite
on repère au niveau de compétences chez
moi qui m'autorise à être affectés au
boudin aux renseignements généraux je
suis affecté à la lutte antiterroriste
je protège un président de la république
nicolas sarkozy occasionnellement
dominique de villepin premier ministre
je suis présent au moment des attentats
de charlie sur la scène de crime au
stade de france le 13 novembre 2015
ce sont des échecs pour nous mais on a
aussi
et pour des raisons évidentes ciel
évidentes de confidentialité je pourrai
pas les détailler ici mais on a aussi eu
des succès sur la lutte antiterroriste
on a réussi à sauver des vies
quelque part ça a été un parcours
totalement improbable il a été rendu
possible grâce à ses 1 à ces rencontres
providentielles alors il faut savoir
qu'à mon tour j'étais je me sentais
redevable vis-à-vis de ces gens là mais
ces gens là n'avaient pas besoin de moi
donc la meilleure façon pour moi d'être
redevable envers ce qui m'avait été
accordée c'était d'essayer de leur
transmettre alors malgré moi et sans le
savoir j'ai été aussi une personne
providentielle pour des gens et je
laisse eu après
par exemple au moment où j'avais été
désigné pour faire visiter le
commissariat de bobigny à des collégiens
parce que ça des fois des classes
découvertes on va visiter les
institutions etc
dix ans plus tard je me rends à la dgs y
donc la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure pour un rendez vous
professionnel il ya un jeune à l'accueil
qui me dit salut comment tu vas donc moi
premier réflexe je me dis mais c'est qui
celui là il me permet de me tutoyer d'où
il sort alors il retire sa casquette
parce qu'ils étaient en tenue il était
affecté à la sécurité du bâtiment et il
lit tu me reconnais pas julie bah non je
ne sais pas qui tu es et en fait il y
effectivement c'est normal j'ai dix ans
de plus que la dernière fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés donc tu m'as fait visiter le
commissariat de bobigny à 10 ans alors
que j'étais en classe avec nos collèges
et aujourd'hui je suis policier à la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure
donc il était effectivement d'origine
sri lankaise il avait une compétence
linguistique qui affecte sa carrière n'a
pas cessé d'évoluer depuis
ensuite si je pense aussi à cette femme
iranienne alors sur mon premier poste
j'étais affecté à la cité administrative
de bobigny il s'agissait de patrouille
et sécuriser les bâtiments
administratifs il y avait la direction
des étrangers ou qu'il arrive l'heure
que j'attendais pour laquelle je me
ratais c'est à dire l'heure de la
fermeture des bâtiments donc un moment
sur le dernier bâtiment je vais fermer
la porte et j'aperçois une famille
familles qui attendent leur demande ce
qu'ils attendent puisque les guichets
sont fermés quand je leur parle ils sont
effrayés et je suis en tenue chez en
bleu je suis grand je suis imposants ils
ont peur et donc la femme se saisit du
bébé ils sortent ils obtempèrent tout de
suite et moi j'aurais dit non mais
attendez il parle pas français il parle
anglais j'essaye de comprendre la
situation en fait il est en train de se
réchauffer à l'intérieur du bâtiment où
qu'ils étaient là pour cette unique
raison donc je leur pose la question de
leur situation j'appelle la responsable
on leur demande de nous présenter leurs
documents administratifs il avait ce
qu'on appelait un sauf conduit donc il
s'agissait de réfugiés politiques
iraniens et il avait une attestation de
l'office de l'office de l'immigration
qui somme mais l'état de les héberger
dans les plus brefs délais donc on a
interprété les documents pour eux je les
ai conduit au centre d'hébergement et je
continue mon travail tranquillement et
un jour au comice a dominé on dit tiens
je crois qu'on t'appelle et qu'elle ne
quitte apple en bas quinze jeunes me
parle en français j'ai un petit doute en
fait c'est lui en deux ans c'était
l'adolescent qui a accompagné la famille
il a appris le français en deux ans il
s'inscrit à la fac de droit et il me dit
j'ai aimé la façon dont vous nous avez
permis d'exercer nos droits et je pense
que je vais devenir avocat grâce à vous
moi je suis bouleversée
alors je continue ma petite carrière
puis bon syndicaliste dans la police
c'est jamais évident
donc
survient la crise des gilet jaune les
attentats terroristes en série et donc
je suis amené à devenir une personne
publique et intervenir dans les médias
fait partie d'un syndicat minoritaire et
au fur et à mesure de notre exposition
médiatique notre nombre d'adhérents
augmente crime boucle whatsapp sur
laquelle on communique avec nos
adhérents ceux qui ont des difficultés
peuvent nous solliciter à tout moment
puis je finis ma carrière de policier
est un moment où je décide de passer à
autre chose c'est qu'elle travaille
énergivores c'est un travail
profondément éprouvant et donc je prends
la décision d'entamer une seconde
carrière dans l'administration
et au moment où je quitte le groupe voit
saab en saluant mes collègues l'un d'eux
me dit attends j'ai un truc à te dire
j'avais chez moi mon pistolet dans la
bouche et je t'ai entendu parler à la
télé je me suis dit qu'une alternative
était possible et que la vie valait
peut-être la peine d'être vécue
donc c'était un message extrêmement
lourd à porter savez je pèse 110 kg
j'essaye de perdre du poids il m'a
rajouté une tonne en une phrase voilà
donc
[Applaudissements]
alors tout ça en fait pour vous dire
que chacun d'entre nous chacun d'entre
vous en faites ce sera amené à faire des
rencontres providentielles cours de sa
vie la seule condition pour qu'elle le
devienne celle que vous puissiez affûté
suffisamment vos sens votre esprit votre
perception des mots et des actes pour
pouvoir y être sensible et en faire
quelque chose
pourquoi de votre tour vous puissiez au
cours de votre existence et au cours de
vos carrières qui sont plutôt
prometteuses pour la plupart d'entre
vous
que vous puissiez par un geste de bonté
et de générosité
un geste gratuit devenir à votre tour la
personne croÿ dedans ciel que vous soyez
vous auriez aimé rencontrer tout
simplement soyez la personne
providentielle que vous auriez aimé
rencontrer et je vous le répète soyez à
votre tour la personne providentielle
que vous auriez aimé rencontrer
ce qui m'est arrivé peut vous arriver à
tous
de la même manière
évidemment vous serez pour certains
amené à rencontrer des personnes
toxiques qui joueront le rôle inverse de
celui de personne providentielle il
faudra aussi de la même manière
apprendre à les identifier et à vous en
éloignez voilà alors la clé de cette
société c'est cette générosité qui m'a
été octroyée la clé de tous nos
problèmes actuellement chacun
ce mur derrière l'individualisme
derrière la recherche de profits on vit
dans une société du profit immédiat ou
quand on a investi un euro c'est pour en
récupérer deux il n'y a plus rien de
gratuit mais par des dons symbolique
parfois vous pouvez sauver des vies ce
qui m'est arrivé peut aussi vous arriver
que vous soyez là personne a rencontré
ou la personne qui rencontrera merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]